it's your friendly neighbor and paratah
here I put it here now so that you know
I'm doing the sound effects alright if
you hear like a cool sound effect when
there's just maybe not that one but like
this is my vegetarian why you know I'm
the one doing that [ __ ] I control it all
all right
stepping it up in 2017 family friendly
Felix here how you doing today we're
going to learn more about just about
anything you can always expand your mind
get more knowledge today we got to look
at developing psychic powers no no
[Music]
that's right I just made you like the
video I watched his instructional video
and that's how I learned and I'm willing
to share this is an instrument oh really
play music by itself with practice and
training by someone beautiful music can
be heard hey this one can play music by
itself
without practice and trainings you can
only produce sound the same is true for
your other natural talents like running
nurturing and using your psychic
abilities like a running nurturing and
using your psychic abilities it's just
like running a basic part of you they're
already within you race there is natural
to you is breathing not just a kiss and
training you can also develop your own
special psychic talent to bring harmony
beauty and success into your life well
you got none of those hi know just like
a coach or music teacher or guide I'll
help you discover your own natural
psychic challenge and reuse them you use
these talents every day without even
thinking with practice you can develop
and use them anytime in anywhere stop
appearing out of knowing them please say
hi there it's pretty perfect here are
eight different types of psychic
abilities in fact you may be using one
or many of your psychic abilities
already in your life what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] talking about I mean wait she
knows she knows about my psychic
abilities that's right
other psychic readers Kindle can read
other people's that can feel other
people's power my power psychic ability
must be so strong that it intersects
time from 1996 a VHS tape my god my god
with repetition you'll just get better
and you can practice these exercises
every day in your daily life if you do
not get results right away look and see
where you block yourself where your
defenses or fears are coming in it [ __ ]
you damn it she knows about my blockage
No
damn it if you're blocking yourself with
me on this video you're certainly using
those same blocks in your life I'm not
blocking you no no no I'm not blocking
you and that is nothing to do with my
life okay you do not look like my mother
you don't know me this is not a class
your abilities are already there the
results will come
it feels like such a [ __ ] cult
doesn't it you're talking all this
mumbo-jumbo you already have these
powers there are several oh stop in fact
once you practice them you can do them
without even thinking and nobody can
tell you're doing them kind of like when
you fart situate yourself so that your
body is comfortable okay you can be
sitting or reclining again and place
your hands on an inanimate object anyone
will do the size of a chair or couch or
bed the telephones while you're talking
the desk or table you can hold an
inanimate steering wheel of your car in
that traffic jam and place your feet on
the floor or the end of the couch or bed
if you're lying down okay and then just
let any tensions you might feel move
through your hands into the inanimate
objects and through your feet into the
floor
just let it flow you make your tingling
or rush of energy or you may feel
nothing at all in the extreme this is
not a measure of psychic ability we're
not testing
remember there's just too soon
[Music]
no that didn't work okay maybe maybe I
will never have second flowers but
there's one thing I struggled with my
entire life I've never been cool at
parties
and I bet I'm not the only one I bet you
feel the same way
well I found it I found a tape from 1986
backwards that will definitely give us
the right answer let's watch already the
intro it's extremely cool I know I'll
never be as cool no it's what you got em
it hey you he you've got to watch this
he won't believe the eye all right I'm
gonna cut this piece of string yeah like
so okay all right okay I'm gonna put it
in my hand yeah bring one end over here
one end over here tug on both ends of
course and blow on it but it was never
together
voila Oh tricks and gags to amaze your
friends yeah llama
I mean camel oh my god that's so cool
how do they do that
this set is so [ __ ] fresh dude they
got a [ __ ] cow couch with neon lights
they got a balloon they got a cool dog
with glasses that coffee table it's off
the hook what is happening here as I was
saying this is show off show off is
about how to be the life of the party
you are about to see some of the
funniest most startling outrageous and
cool tricks you've ever seen damn this
dog is cool man and remember these three
rules number one okay be cool [ __ ] you
number two have fun and I'm not Italy I
don't huh it's not for me because if
you're not having fun how can you expect
your friends to help of your time I
don't know and number three have courage
weirwood Washington B if he hadn't had
the courage to show off and throw that
silver dollar across the river [ __ ]
you're in an instructional video all
right though don't get ahead of yourself
boy
where would I be if I did not have my
incredible strange Rick you need to set
this part out before your friends come
in first to take a way he's gonna teach
me that string trick now take the middle
of the string and pull the parts out and
then you twist them I do like this to
make him look like ends ah okay now I'm
take the agile sheet and put them
together so they look like they're
attached are you chaining twisted yeah
ah now you're ready to amaze your
friends you take scissors and you cut
horizontally
like so time on this end blow on it and
the Big Finish
[Music]
looks like
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that's so cool
so screams is actually just made out of
other strings who'da thunk it man that's
crazy dog we live in a crazy world man
hey Sal look you see this [ __ ] oh my god
hey guys
family friendly Felix here got a magic
trick for you all you need
I mean I have a string here and as you
can see it's set to string and then here
we have the end of it I'm going to cut
it here and then I'm going to grab it
and you make sure you pull it and then
you say something I do boy detective if
CJ car I'll dig up I ought to go when
it's your boy Jack city cat imma kill
myself it's me it was me
[Music]